bap bap bap what is this new thing where
people on Instagram live or on their
story or something will pretend like
everyone is asking them a question it's
super insignificant and they'll be like
exhausted by everyone asking and they
pretend like they're doing everyone some
big favor by revealing something they've
been like withholding that people have
been on the edge of their seats to know
about they'll be like okay everyone's
asking what I do to my split ends so I'm
I'm gonna just do a video I'm just gonna
do a livestream just about my sweat ends
cuz like I know everyone's asking no
one's asking everyone's asking when
they're gonna go back to work
everyone's asking when there's gonna be
a vaccine no one's asking you about your
split ends like two people maybe like
maybe everyone is asking what kind of
honey I put in my tea so I'm gonna do a
thing where I show you guys the honey
that I put in my tea just so you guys
stop asking like don't don't let two
crazy people dictate your content even
if someone did ask that ignore them it's
a dumb question
ignore them lock them don't make the
rest of your followers have to watch you
talk about your split ends for 40
minutes
one person is not everyone we have such
a false sense of importance Oh before
you take a question seriously from one
of your followers first you have to
check their bio to make sure they're
sane and if the picture is either a cat
or a fictional princess don't take their
question if their bio has more than
three emojis and if those emojis are
either a high-heel a fairy or the monkey
holding its ears don't listen to that
person I don't know what I'm doing
face I'm calming myself down this is my
new quarantine coping strategy just calm
down